the world is now one big small town  but within that virtual Town Square  there are tiers of relationships degrees  of intimacy and everyone deserves a  different amount of you  a different side  now where are those boundaries lie  is up to you I try to wait 48 hours  before posting and sharing  because that way I can be present in  private with the people I love before  calculating how I'm going to publicly  position it  and post with purpose  before I share I ask myself why what's  the purpose and most importantly how  does it serve the people I love  because cultivating a private life is  precious  it's sacred  its value is inherent in what you don't  share